i'm talking about syntax i'm not talking
about all the other aspects because like
conjugating verbs and long times i'm not
that's not you know enjoyable for me
either but what i'm talking about is
sentence structure and that is important
to allow you to speak
the language with confidence and so
a lot of students if they don't learn
about syntax how it actually works and
and
they they do translate word for words or
first language into the other language
and that's not how you speak another
language so yes you need to accept the
language for what it is and i definitely
tell people to do that but i also show
them how to think in a language and
that's important how do you get to that
point where you can use these tools and
actually think and control the language
because i mean there's a difference a
lot of people they buy phrase books and
so they learn certain set phrases but
they can't use that phrase in other
situations and so they're not getting as
much benefit out of those that learning
opportunity as they could if they
understand how the structure worked and
then how they could use it to their
advantage in different ways and so you
can know that in many different ways and
that's why i kind of lay them all
out in the book i'm pointing them out to
you but i'm not saying here's other ways
you can get out you can use technology
as steve's suggesting but there are
other ways to get about it you can you
can use books to advance you can use
audio cassettes and i put them all out
there so you can pick and choose which
way you want it which way you want to go
about it but i also point out to you the
very basic elements and so you have
those tools in order to move forward
because what you don't know that holds
you back so as much as you can inform
yourself as much as you can become aware
of before you enter the situation or
even while you're in it
that's going to help you out so don't
like confront those you know common
challenges that people face and
translate word forward and you know
cause yourself endless amounts of labor
that's it's unnecessary but
you know use what's out there to your
advantage
exactly and i mean that's one of the
things is because people do speak very
fast because they know the language very
well and you don't it's like trying to
you know hold on to a train that's
moving at a lightning speed and one of
the things that you know i should
mention this is that adults suffer from
something that linguists call the
poverty the stimulus and basically what
that means in layman's terms is they're
not getting enough repetition out of the
situation and so when you're listening
to people and they're moving at a quick
pace one of the things you can do is i
mean you can obviously stop and say oh
well can you slow down a bit you know
that's but there are other ways that you
can do that and still participate in the
conversation and so one of them is that
you can change taylor's situation or the
conversation back to something that you
do know so the words you're encountering
that you don't know so if you're
bringing it back to said like if you're
if you
if i'm talking to you about something
about cars and you say oh that reminds
me of a day that i went and did
something that you really enjoy you're
bringing the conversation back to
vocabulary that you know and then the
person is going to be engaging in that
conversation but they're also they're
going to be talking about something you
know some vocabularies you already know
but some of the words and the structures
that they're using are going to be
different so it's going to allow you to
build your vocabulary at a nice even
pace so you're not kind of overwhelmed
by a whole bunch of words that you don't
know another thing to do is if you're a
group situation
the people the native speakers around
you they have the ears that you don't
have so you might hear someone say a
really great word that you didn't
understand that you yourself would like
to use you can actually say to them oh
what was that word they heard it they
understood it because it's their their
first language right and you can use
them to your advantage you say oh what
was that word and they'll say it to you
again and so you can ask them later what
was that word i wanted to write it down
or whatever so you and you're getting
them to say it again so it's more
repetition for you see how you're
creating more repetition out of the
situation and so you're turning things
to
tables to your advantage
just if i could just comment a little
bit on that um
one of the difficult to have with
getting back to the syntax thing is the
explanation of the structure
those explanations there are so many of
them and there are so many exceptions
that in the end you're faster off you're
better off and faster to go straight to
the language and therefore by repetitive
listening and similarly with have it's
great to have these strategies for when
you're talking to native speakers
uh how successful they'll be the problem
is that you're not able to control the
situation when you're with the native
speaker
it may not it may be that you don't
speak very well the native speaker is
simply not interested in talking to you
period
i mean you know uh
if i walk into shanghai somebody comes
up and says can i practice my english
with you well no
you know
so it's not obvious that they're
interested and if you go out with people
i've been in japan and for the longest
time i was bumping along because they're
not going to slow down
they're having fun they're bare whatever
they're yucking up and they're not going
to slow everything down they're going to
slow down for me once
and after a while like i say steve you
know you work it out and so you haven't
had a beer
so so my point there is that in in
learning and i'm not saying technology
is the answer but i'm saying
input
okay build yourself up through input
then you have an output opportunity you
do well or you don't do well you pick up
on some things that you are unable to
express then you go back and try and
learn those things through your input
because the input you can control you
can always have i always have my little
ipod shuffle with me
you can always have it with you you can
read wherever you want you can listen
wherever you want so you can do a lot of
stuff on your own under a situation that
you control then you're thrown into a
situation where you have to use the
language which is out of your control
but i just i just want to make the point
that that repetitive listening and the
things that you can control is where you
can really constantly immerse yourself
in the language as much as you want
just because we've had all the questions